this video I'm going to talk about
dengue virus replication and
pathophysiology of dingo so here we have
a man of our tropical country and we
will see how this man will get affected
by the dengue
so then you is most common in the
tropical areas not in the temperate
regions so say for instance this is a
man from a tropical region and here is a
mosquito who bites the man and thus the
dengue is transmitted to the body of
this man so the was cute Oh for the
dengue virus transmission is called
Eddie's Egypt II it is Egypt II so when
the mosquito bites when the mosquito
bites with its saliva it injects the
dengue virus so here we have or what we
call we have the epidermis the epidermis
region beneath that we have the damaged
region here the dengue virus is injected
by this mosquito and there are some
dendritic cells we need these Darmok
epidermis region in the darkness we have
some dendritic cell this is our
epidermis and we also have some
macrophages denoting as MSI and we are
noting it as TC also what we have we
have granule secreting
basophils we have basophils so what
happens this is dengue virus will
actually infect the dendritic cell or
the macrophages so dendritic cell has a
particular type of cell receptor called
the DC sign and the macrophages has a
particular type of receptor or which are
mannose type receptor mr- type receptor
so this dengue virus can actually get
inside the dendritic cell via either of
these two receptors and once and we will
look in details how the dengue virus get
inside and cause harm to this kind of
cells however when these cells are
harmed it will migrate to the lymphoid
system along the immune cells so these
dendritic cell is affected this
dendritic cell is affected so as the
macrophage is also affected here so they
will migrate why these live to PR the
live capillary the lymph vessel they
will migrate wire this lymph vessel and
go to other lymphoid organ organs and
this is how the infection that spread
into the system extrapolation so when
these macrophages are infected and this
dendritic cell are infected they will
secrete some interference both of them
will secrete some interference so
actually these interference work like a
cytotoxic alarm so what happened beneath
the dermis where we have capillaries
from these capillaries these capillaries
are the immune cells like our cytotoxic
T cell that is cd+
toxic diesel and also the NK cells the
natural killer cells will come off into
the dermis region so here I'm drawing a
capillary you can see the capillary
cells you are the capillary cells so
these are from these capillary cells the
natural killer cells will come out and
also the cd8 plus T cells will come out
and these two cells together will mount
an inflammatory response so we have seen
that from here in dengue the dengue
virus is now in our system in
circulation and now it can move
throughout the body it can go into the
liver it can go into other organs it can
encounter all other immune cells and it
has been seen that the dengue virus is
not specific towards any receptor so it
can use a multiple receptors and can get
inside our cell for instance it can
recognize DC sign as well as it can
recep it can also recognize the mannose
type receptors it can also sense other
type of receptors so it's cells that are
infected by these dengue virus are quite
broad so here we would see a the
structure of the dengue virus a little
bit so here we have the dengue virus so
ding-dang virus comes under the family
flag we'll be reading these flabby v d
DS r plus strand a single-stranded RNA
RNA viruses and this single-stranded RNA
get inside the cell and are got
transferred converted into negative
stranded R
and then again to the last stranded RNA
so here we have some proteins metric
proteins called B proteins
another type of proteins we call C
proteins so these kind of structures are
common for all families of all the
member of the family of lab ability so
what here we have the single strand RNA
genome and if we just draw some genomic
features of these the dengue virus we
will see that it has a 5 prime end utr
where it has look like structures a lot
of hair pins after that it has its this
is 5 prime UTR then it has a lot of
coding region this is the or F I'm not
specifying all the proteins that are
encoded by this over F but I'm just
generally telling it it is ORF and then
it has what we call a 3 prime region and
3 prime region it has a lot of hair pins
this is 3 prime so this is 5 prime so
this is 3 prime UTR
it has a lot of hairpins so just a Gina
just to recapitulate what is the genomic
features of this virus so it has a
linear SS RNA genome and definitely that
is plus sense that means this RNA what I
have drawn here could be directly used
by the cell to produce protein
structural proteins and so it size is
somehow like nine point seven to 12 kilo
base pairs 3 prime end don't have poly a
tail but have hairpin
and five prime and have three hydroxy
methyl cap now as this is the common
features we have looked in now we will
see how these are de and V how these
dengue virus how this dingo virus can
get inside to this macrophage or say
these dendritic cell and can replicate
and can multiply dangu is also known as
a dango is also known as breakbone fever
or because what happens in dingle it's a
severe joint pin so here I am drawing
the leg of this individual so here you
can see in these joints such as this
joint of femur and the lower limb severe
joint pin is one of the characteristic
of these fever in this dengue fever
so now now let's zoom into another cell
and see a looming to the macrophage and
see how then you can affect it so here
we have the cell membrane here we have
the cell membrane and surprisingly no
specific receptor against dengue virus
was reported it appears that ding you
can use a lot of receptors like DC signs
like a man''ôs type receptor they can
use lectins so for instance this this is
the dengue virus and it's attached to
this cell surface receptor after
attaching to this particular cell
surface receptor after attaching to this
particular cell surface receptor what
happened
clattering mediated endocytosis will
take place
so clattering mediated endocytosis will
take place it is the flattering coat all
around the endocytosis vesicle and what
happened there is a pH which is less
than 7
that means the environment is acidic
inside the vesicle so in this condition
the surface proteins that I have
discussed earlier with undergo
conformational change and this protein
will actually bind to the surface of
these vesicles and actually release the
mRNA actually the genomic material that
means the single-stranded RNA once
release the plus strand this is RNA gets
converted into the negative strand cases
RNA using this negative strand as a
template it is again converted into more
ASIS RNA and this replicated esses RNA
would be later used as a viral genomic
material so what happens some of the
plus RNAs RNA sits upon the ribosome and
synthesize protein and this protein gets
inside the rough endoplasmic reticulum
where the gathers together forming the
matrix actually a poly protein is first
form and after from the poly protein
they are cleaved into small protein
units structural proteins and other
proteins so it will get inside this
rough endoplasmic reticulum and here the
protein of the virus the matrix protein
would be assembled here and then what
happened the vesicle continuing these
virus and here we have the genomic
material also would
get inside the goggle Network here in
the gong-gong key Network this virus
would be prepared packaged and ready to
be delivered to other cell so in this a
budding vesicle the virus is totally
ready with its genomic material so this
virus gets totally ready and enveloped
and here you can see the virus is
released and ready to infect other cells
and when another mosquito with which
doesn't infect it with the virus
actually takes up the mêlée from
infected person this virus get inside
another mosquito one thing to be noted
that these dengue virus also reside in
the saliva a grand of the mosquito that
is why these dengue virus can be
transmitted to host to host that means
the humans when it bites a human so as
per summary we have seen that dengue
virus comes under the family of flava
vdd and its main vector it's the
mosquito it is Egypt II and this virus
mediated dengue fever is most common in
the tropical areas the warm areas and
mainly the immune cells are affected not
a single type of cell multiple cells
could be affected the mechanism is
exactly not known the receptors of which
dengue virus chews it also not known but
the dengue virus use multiple receptors
like DC sign and macrophages the mannose
receptor etc and it ultimately gets
circulated into the systemic circulation
however this dengue virus has the
structural feature of dengue virus is a
protein which help in fusion in the
latter part of the cell the replication
cycle and the viral the viral genome is
single-stranded RNA in a positive sense
and the symmetry of the virus is
icosahedral symmetry and the virus how
it infects I have already talked about
it in detail the most important event is
that the pH mediated conformational
change of the surface glycoprotein II
which helps this virus to get docked
into the vesicle surrounding it and
releasing its genomic material that
means the single strand RNA the rest of
the process goes as if from the ER to
Golgi and then the virus is packaged and
released and now virus is ready to
infect other cell I hope you liked it
enjoy and thank you please subscribe